jean claude félix tchicaya bonjour merci
d'être en direct avec nous sur rt france
alors tout d'abord quelle est la
situation actuellement à bamako
moi c'est une situation explosive mais
qui en ce moment connaît une accalmie
due à une décision de ce mouvement dit
du 5 juin
mais même si avant le 5 juin couvert une
une demande assez forte de la part de la
société malienne qui est arrive à
saturation assez de même on pourrait
dire de sidération devant une 1 sec d
insécurité une insécurité généralisée
sur le plan économique sur le plan
social sur l'insécurité ou pourrait dire
même la non sûreté en état de plus en
plus exsangue
un bilan très négatif de la présidence
et puis bien sûr le terrorisme dans tout
dans toute la région du sahel et
particulièrement au vally donc il y a eu
au début de ce mois de juin une demande
de démission de la part de ce mouvement
très hétéroclite on trouve un peu un peu
tout le monde donc des anciens ministres
qui sont partis donc du gouvernement
d'yves écart des munitions de travailler
avec d'autres gouvernements avant ib cas
en tout cas toute une société civile
aussi et est en branle et dans les rues
de bamako et ailleurs on peut dire
qu'une très grande partie du mali
demandes soit une démission d'yves et
cas même si aujourd'hui elle est plus
entre guillemets à l'ordre du jour c'est
plutôt la démission maintenant du
premier ministre et une dissolution de
l'assemblée nationale
il y a eu des les guettent sur une
première délégation de la cedeao qui a
demandé qui demandait donc que les deux
parties puissent s'entendre pour un
gouvernement d'union nationale le mali a
déjà connu des gouvernements d'union
nationale qui ont fini par imploser
donc ce qui est demandé par le mouvement
du n 5 s'est peut-être accordé le fait
que monsieur yves écarts restent pouvoir
mais lui retirer une bonne substance une
bonne partie de ses prérogatives en tant
que chef d'état dont sur le plan
juridique sur le plan narcissique même
c'est difficilement acceptable de la
part de monsieur sy beckham et il est
comme poussé à démissionner par une la
plus grande partie du mali vous l'avez
dit c'est la troisième médiation qui est
organisé pour trouver une issue à cette
colère dans la rue mais également du
mouvement dit du 5 juin le mouvement
d'opposition est ce que vous pensez que
cette médiation a des chances d'aboutir
cette fois ci mais en tout cas ça paraît
très périlleux probable peu probable la
démission de monsieur becca n'est pas
dans la feuille de route de de ses
présidents des pays frontaliers avec des
présidents qui ont quand même une
autorité dans la région il manque
peut-être le roi du maroc et le
président algérien qui sont d'ordre la
cedeao mais qui sont des pays
frontaliers et qui sont très attentifs à
la situation malienne le premier
ministre ne veut pas démissionner il ya
encore l'ancien de seconde qui est
arrivée seconde aux présidentielles aux
présidentielles aux dernières
présidentielles qui a été enlevée il n'a
pas toujours
il est toujours pas revenu dans la dans
la vie civile est donc libéré
donc on est vraiment devant une
situation assez explosive on ne peut pas
dire aujourd'hui qu'il y aurait donc de
quoi être optimiste le peuple ce que
veut le peuple c'est d'abord la paix
donc tout les ans sécurité puisse être
donc retrouvé que l'état retrouve
retrouve une bonne marche et que toutes
les questions sécuritaires de sûreté le
terrorisme qui avance tel un cheval de
troie l'intérieur aussi peut-être de ce
mouvement donc il ya nombre
d'inquiétudes
on espère que ce sommet on pourra dire
ben mami li saumet parce que il ya
vraiment une
les présidents qui compte dans la région
sans remonter la tension est même les
pressions de la communauté
internationale
est ce que pour résoudre cette crise on
doit d'abord régler le contentieux
électoral parce que on sait qu' il y à
une crise politique mais il ya également
une crise institutionnelle le mali n'a
plus de gouvernement depuis 40 jours
on sait que la cour constituait
constitutionnel continue de cristalliser
un petit peu les les tensions elle a
invalidé d'ailleurs une partie des
résultats des élections législatives est
favorisée selon l'opposition le
président ibrahim boubacar keïta
oui c'est un véritable casus belli est
venue enflammer précipité la présence
massive dans les rues de bamako on avait
rarement vu toute la société civile et
ce mouvement qui comprend donc cinq
mouvements à l'intérieur d'un mouvement
qu'on appelle le mouvement de m 5
très hétéroclite à en trouver des
personnes de gauche de droite des
mouvements vraiment avec l'imam dicko au
dessus qui est là entre guillemets pour
une garde toute sa porte est ouverte
pour ceux qui sont à l'intérieur de
l'opposition c'est l'extérieur tout le
monde va voir l'imam dicko dans cette
dans cette crise
ce qu'on peut dire c'est que la cour
constitutionnelle
sa décision est très discutée et
l'opposition ne comparent rogner sur ce
qu'elle demande à la constitution c'est
de revenir sur une décision qui
semble-t-il est inique et donnerait donc
un avantage non méritée au pouvoir merci
beaucoup jean claude félix tchicaya
d'avoir réagi ce matin sur rtl france je
rappelle que vous êtes chercheur à
l'institut prospective et sécurité en
europe